bonjour philippe pozzo di borgo bonjour
vous êtes aujourd'hui à versailles pour
une conférence car vous êtes parent de
l'eau ch l'office chrétien pour les
personnes handicapées votre visage et
votre nous sont très médiatisées
aujourd'hui puisque votre histoire et
votre livre le second souffle ont
inspiré le scénario d'intouchables le
film avec liv ynwa omar sy quel est
votre regard aujourd'hui sur le handicap
le même qu'avant c'est dire que
c'était une condition aux galères comme
sa douloureuse et pénible mais si la
condition de beaucoup de gens parce que
le handicap c'est pas du temps fauteuil
handicap c'est souvent est seul donc
vous avez des handicaps très visible et
d'autres moins les handicaps sensoriels
plus ample cape affectif d'un cap
sociaux des incas par l'âge par là mais
dis donc finalement la fragilité est une
condition bien humaine donc morgan a pas
beaucoup changé nous sommes tous un peu
handicapé et avant d'être tétraplégique
vous aviez le même regard sur le
handicap non puisque dans notre société
de performance et j'étais un des
meilleurs dans ce milieu c'était
prototype caricaturale de la société
performance est ce qui nous
caractérisait ces cons bouge et on fait
du bruit mais quand vous bougez vous
faites du bruit ou sais pas ce qu'il se
passe autour d'eux c'est une vague va
taper sur la tête que je me retrouvais
immobile dans un lit d'hôpital un tabac
où j'ai découvert cavell silence et dans
le silence on regarde les choses
différemment c'est ce qui a inspiré ce
livre dont vous parlez c'est que après
quelques années de silence et le décès
de mon épouse qui l'a fait qu'il absolue
bien sûr si vous voulez mettre des mots
sur ses maux ces difficultés de faire
partager aux autres que fait un petit
lancer vous avez retrouvé une manière de
vivre différemment et c'est faisant
l'accident de parapente c'était il ya
vingt ans en 1993 est ce que votre
entourage et les passants ont changé de
regard oui bien sûr les gens sont
déstabilisés sont pris à contre-pied par
leur handicap et donc il faut arriver
nous les handicapés visible ou pas à les
séduire donc c'est à moi de faire
l'effort pour que les autres se sentent
pas mal à l'aise et je peux vous dire
que vous êtes et des parrains abdel
cellou qui est jouée par marcy ouvre
dans le cinéma mais dans la vraie vie
s'appelle abdel et vous avez un vrai
coup de main parce qu'il amène les gens
à vous considérer et s'ils veulent pas
vous pro series va les chercher un peu
brutalement et leur explique que je suis
à peu près normale et quelle est votre
méthode à vous pour séduire les gens et
qu'ils oublient votre handicap
madame vous voulez que je vous dise quoi
faire vous rapprocher un peu
non il faut simplement essayé de parler
et de dire que l'handicap celui très
bien si il est pas tout seul et que je
peux vous apporter quelque chose
j'ai le temps je suis lent silence vous
êtes la récitation et le bruit je vous
apprendrai l'apprendre silence en
apprend beaucoup de choses
donc j'ai eu une fonction dans la
société c'est de remettre les pendules à
l'heure et tous les handicapés faut pas
les cacher c'est ce que fait le cias
dont on fête les 50 ans ce soir et vous
êtes justement le parrain quel est votre
rôle c'est de taper le porte parole avec
les autres et de dire
nous sommes là pour remettre la société
sur ses pieds et le cerf s'ils font ça
depuis 50 ans il aide les handicapés à
se réinsérer à avoir une vie être
considéré et une fois qu'on a disséminé
le handicap de la société 20 sociétés à
mieux et quels sont selon vous les
politiques publiques prioritaires en
termes d'acceptation d'intégration du
handicap dans la société oui beaucoup
l'essentiel c'est de à travers le tissu
associatif
permettre d'irriguer le plus possible
des deniers publics et a pas beaucoup de
deniers publics en période de crise donc
il faut et des associations qui sont
près du terrain et près de la cité et je
pense que ce gouvernement est tout à
fait en faveur de cette notion
l'association irrigué finances et
l'associatif vous aurez un effet
multiplicateur très supérieure à 6 était
une administration centralisée
quel message vous aimeriez faire passer
justement à travers votre rôle de parent
eh bien j'aimerais que les gens pensent
un peu moins un à un nous sommes dans
une société d'égoïsme ou en croque le
bonheur c'est d'accumuler les choses ben
vous vous trompez le bonheur c'est
d'être avec les autres et de partager
avec les autres et de considérer les
autres et considérer la fragilité c'est
vous soigner c'est vous donner le vrai
notion de ce que c'est que la vie est ce
que vous allez en considérant la
faillite et vous avez considéré toutes
les facilités mais sociale les
écologiques
les financières les tout donc mettez le
handicap au milieu la société et vous
irait beaucoup mieux bien merci pour ce
beau message philippe pozzo di borgo et
de nous avoir accordé cette interview
merci